does
Senate in San Francisco
she didn't do something
I think it's no so much for charity
discovering the power building a special
line for line is Alice so we have to
choose which is programs the Royal team
off this doesn't feel a little too crazy
I know a lot of people ask in mind on
your electricity a lot and we kind of
have this debate right last row is when
do we do this through our we have a good
fit with my producing lightning bolts
compare our fingers
I hate you
so when you see them sitting on the
screen
sure looks very excellent thank you Jeff
to my new vampires which not even a
shapeshifter
we do have some ideas for next season
they will I was sitting in an interview
earlier what would be fun for me yeah
that's what their one from the first
season but the problem with that is I'm
very expensive to make CDs which can
cost a thousand dollars and that's just
on our television project you see a suit
like that in movies Venus they stepped
into in fifty thousand three hundred
thousand dollars or maybe was 93 and is
now a whole subscribe character and you
can get our CGI character versus many
shots I think it's really cool what you
guys think of the first season parables
like it it looked like a big animated
see territory so even something else
like Doctor Who you will see where their
seats got so much air around here's some
will say what do you guys think kind of
features you want to say concept Empire
show us protect our particular agency
in her a long time especially when they
started acting my dream was to credit to
actions their kids are like to something
beyond a show where I get to actively do
that
I mean it's amazing and I've learned a
lot from my sensible teaching was the CC
sheets but nothing I wasn't really
really talented in I can really looking
at she takes the time to teach me a lot
of somewhere working is the one woman I
never and you had to do like that
there certain genes get to do extra work
so it has a lot of spots and introduce
yourself to us many involved
say hi my name's isness and I think
their stuff schools as well
how they like to Franklin to the right
this video is actually online the after
after show where Dylan and Rosie are
basically molesting every pieces of
furniture and writers together this
pretty disgusting actually they were
and to me it's a way to show that it
dary he's not being alpha is how most of
the world lives around because he's
working folk hero I'm actually Derek's
got my favorite characters of the show
he was really did a great job with his
transition it was kind of ready to
sacrifice its life hero
wait dinner that come out so to answer
your question is it something
you